why why does my body do this why do I
get the chills when I'm getting sick the
chills feeling is your nervous system
contracting muscles to create heat
inside your body and an attempt to cook
a virus why do I figures hit pruney when
I've been in the water for a long time
scientists believe that pruney fingers
is a function of evolution sparked by
your nervous system humans evolved to
have three fingers to make it easier to
grip things when wet so it would like
the treads on car tires when I get
hungry why does my stomach make that
grumbling noise your stomach is actually
always making digestive noises it's just
one of them see you can hear it better
it's Lord how your voice is muffled in a
full room but it echoes in an empty
Rumble Rumble
what's with that pins and needles
sensation when footballs asleep the
sensation of your foot falling asleep is
actually the feeling of your foot waking
up when you can press a nerve bundle in
your legs it cuts off information from
your foot to your brain the pins and
needle sensation is the feeling of your
nerves rebooting what is that weird
falling sensation or jerk I get
sometimes when I'm about to fall asleep
that feeling is called a hypnotic jerk
your muscles are tired and attempting to
relax all your brain remains awake
creating missed interpretations that
lead to the feeling of falling or loss
of balance what causes brain freeze when
you eat or drink something super cold
the blood vessels around your mouth
constrict the feeling is caused from the
blood rushing back and putting pressure
on your nerves